today we are really excited to hear from
two exceptional sustainability leaders
to talk about how to undertake green
initiatives and in a sector that
required a really unique and nuanced
approach in telling that story so we
have with us when Nikita who is the lead
executive on sustainability for Caesars
Entertainment and Annie longed for
through is CEO of for north america for
Saatchi and Saatchi s which is a
communications and consulting company
whose mission it is to make
sustainability irresistible today we're
in the capable hands of a moderator
Tracy Sharon who is director for the
center of customer insights at Yale
housed at the school of management where
we are today today we're joined also by
our online audience by live stream hi
everyone I think I have some colleagues
of mine tuning in from Germany and make
sure if you have questions for our panel
here to submit them to using the chat
box and I believe Laura will be then
asking the questions to you guys so
before we get into today I would just
like to thank some of the people
responsible for making this happen from
the yale center for customer insights
thank you too Tracy as well as Heather
Fitzgerald and Zoe Lloyd from the Yale
Center for Business in the environment
Stuart to Q and Amy bad MA thank you
very much these are the two centers
who've been hosting this series our
media partner for today was for the
series actually was sustainable brands
you may know this website fantastic
resource they also have a big conference
coming up in June which we're all
excited to be at I encourage you to
check that out so there's been several
students who really led the effort in
putting this series together in this
talk today and I want to thank them very
much maritza Galicia in particular lead
today's organizing and Rachel freed and
lauritz franchini
also here today and have done a
wonderful job so thank you again from
decra and over to you Tracy I think we
have a bit less than one hour we're
going to finish slightly early because
there's a Dean's meeting that some of
the students here need to be at and so
we'll keep an eye on the on the clock
but otherwise welcome and thank you very
much thanks thank you both for coming
when we conceived of this series nearly
a year ago we really thought about how
any sustainability project was built by
a team and by partnerships so we wanted
to talk with assisted partnerships like
sustainability operation sustainability
marketing sustainability and design and
today we're lucky enough to talk to one
of my favorite kind of partnerships and
that's client agency partnership so
thank you and and with this audience we
don't get to hear these perspectives
very often so it's great you're here and
to start up a note on how we're going to
run this I will start out with a handful
of questions that the students helped
help me craft and then I will throw it
to the audience here and online and as
Anastasia mentioned we'll be wrapping up
probably around twelve thirty five to
get you guys on your way so let's start
with a little context and if you two
could tell me about yourself your career
Gwen maybe you can start out and i gotta
say looking at your resume i was curious
that you started out as a consultant in
tunisia how did you move from a
consultant in tunisia so now the VP of
sustainability and community affairs at
caesars true so I guess you could say my
my career was really following my my
passion which with my work and in that
case i graduated from university of
washington from undergrads and wanted to
go anyplace in the continent of africa
because i was more familiar with the
asia-pacific region and Europe have been
studied there and had
she gotten very ill and Tunisia and
moved to back home to Hawaii to recover
got a little bored started looking
around for work and was fascinated by
this field of consumer market research
and I'm just very interested in a
continuous era of learning and kind of
being the sponge or the the goldmine of
information because it's it's I guess
how am I my mind works where I'm
constantly looking for something new or
different your interest that interest me
which drew me to Guam so my boss in
Hawaii called me up one day and said I
want you to take a job in Guam and we
open up a market research arm there stay
there for four years fast forward after
nine eleven to Las Vegas and the
connection then with Harris but I was
interested in moving out of consulting
into the client side of the business
didn't quite know what to do and sell
this opportunity and government affairs
communications and a couple years in
terms of a chief of staff position for
the head of the senior management team
over that area and really all this time
over the course of ten years so uh I
guess more interest in Community Affairs
social justice issues and sort of the
newer more recent exposure around the
Bremen also see the sustainability side
came up when our CEO needed to find
someone to organize a strategy so this
that was seven years ago pany I've got
to say that in the freezes all over and
you guys have branded it well this
making sustainability irresistible yeah
tell us how you a CEO at such yes make
that happen in your work and the the
term is fantastic in that it's one of
the more emotional terms within this
context of really scientific and very
sort of data-driven discussion and so
when you talk about irresistibility
everyone kind of leans forward and says
what are you talking about but the idea
behind it is that so we're not going to
make
change happen if we continue to talk
about the world ending the world burning
up the polar bears dying and all of us
having no future for our grandchildren
that's it's not it's not motivating it
doesn't help people understand what they
should do to actually participate in
change so we think about yours a
stability as looking at the abundance
the opportunity the social equality the
you know joy that sustainability can
bring and making it so irresistible to
consumers that they actually opt in and
they participate whether they're doing
it because polar bears are dying or not
they choose to participate in a way
that's really productive for the rest of
the world and how did your career path
get you to this place and I started out
in journalism and moved into
communications and then I think my sort
of aha moment was a convergence of
inspiration from my family my parents
and my sisters and having my second
child which is a big trigger for a lot
of people having a child and then also
almost a dare from my then boss because
I went back to work after maternity
leave and said i would like to start a
sustainability practice i've been here
for years and i'm a little bored and
this is an up-and-coming thing this is
2007 and her reaction within two seconds
was there is no way you will make money
at that and i still have that email
because that was the nice dare that I
needed to motivate me both from a sort
of career challenge and an economic
point of view and the personal passion
was already there that's great for for
some context for those who haven't read
the the several case studies though are
real answers at this point when can you
really give a overview of some of the
programs that you've led sure um unsere
at caesars just wanted to give you in a
context of seizures as well so a lot of
people think that seizures operates only
in Las Vegas and just has a seizures
brand but we have 14 brands there's
World Series of Poker their seizures
Bailey's Harris horseshoe flamingo Rio
harris planet hollywood showboat and a
few others and we have mini hotel chain
with mini hotel chain but it's about
45,000 hotel rooms throughout our
properties we have 50 properties
surrounded most of the u.s. North
America when in Canada mostly the US and
two and a half million square feet of
convention space so 50,000 15 million
square feet of enclosed air-conditioned
space if you think about all of this the
company grew up where 80 years old as a
company we grew up by mergers and
acquisitions so we look at our buildings
or facilities are much older than
competitors we are gaming first but now
broadly speaking more hospitality so my
my background started in the market
research area in the company so I came
on board prior to the acquisition of
Caesars Entertainment and we looked like
I guess the the base interest around
understanding the customers
understanding what our employees also
wanted to see in here and connect to the
pal they wanted to connect with the
business but also the public perception
of the corporation in jurisdictions that
we operate is very important because
it's literally a license to operate and
the first two questions that a regulator
policymaker asks or not necessary what
what we're doing around environment but
what are you doing for our local
businesses and what are you doing for
our economy so just look kind of put any
context with my my scope of work it's
it's both on the social and
environmental side of policies and
strategies we have a very decentralized
company and with the 70,000 employees
mostly throughout North America but to
pull it up into one overarching policy
her strategy that was they started from
the bottom up I created a team with some
colleagues to put a top-down approach to
our long-term wanted to be one of the
leaders in the broader hospitality
industry on the environmental side on
the social sustainability side looking
to
balance it out in terms of looking at
ways to monetize our social impacts
looking at raising the awareness around
what score to our business so that would
be social safeguards and responsible
gaming so I'm trying to be very succinct
in a very long response and and how does
how do the programs that you work
together that you work together on in
the last couple of years how do they
represent kind of the portfolio of
clients you work with Matt Saachi
similarities differences and I mean
Sachi has kind of three core buckets of
work we do strategy work really helping
companies figure out what it is they
should be doing and sort of how to do it
engagement work which is mostly around
employee engagement and then
communication so internal external
communication and so we don't really
have a typical type of client except to
say that we don't really were not very
interested in working with companies
that are sort of at the compliance level
like if they're just doing what has to
be done that's not particularly exciting
we want the companies that I have an
authentic commitment to of the long-term
journey of sustainability and then we
want to help them figure out what that
journey looks like and how to get there
and and caesars is sort of the perfect
example I think of the clients we want
we like working with because they tap
into all the pieces of our business you
know they hired us originally for
strategy work but now we're doing a lot
of communications work for them so it's
really nice to work with a company that
seized the opportunity and saw it you
know pretty early in there in the scheme
of things so so there's a question there
that we've been kicking around quite a
bit this week about the inherent tension
in organizations and industries often
about the being a great corporate
citizen in a really holistic way versus
taking on bits of corporate citizenship
you know a sustainability project here
a social responsibility project here or
there this tension this continuum seems
but the tension seems high ending in the
gaming industry because I think there's
a lot of skepticism of a gaming
organization being socially responsible
how do you balance this skepticism with
the good work you're actually doing the
the real programs particularly the
programs within sustainability should
you ever run into some skepticism
challenges skepticism only when we go
externally public presentations but i
know i think it's it's interesting where
you no matter what i feel that as a
professional matter what industry i
choose to work in i would have some
level of skepticism because my tendency
might be to work for a large corporation
so that's the one thing as an
entertainment company you in in the
nature of our business we're literally
given a license to operate and that
license operate was provided in
jurisdictions where there was almost no
industry so Joliet Illinois was the
prison industry Jenica Mississippi were
former cotton fields so all these areas
were built or downtown New Orleans was
needed an area to be revitalized and it
was clearly areas that a company to
bring in literally thousands of jobs or
on average 1500 jobs and a large tax
base was important for these
partnerships so our lead in time to
these newer jurisdictions were very much
i would say three four or five years on
in baltimore now it's it's about a five
year wrap up so i would say that the
skepticism o tend to always be there but
the fact is that the the culture of the
company is is always something that has
been long standing around considering
ourselves the the white hat company of
the gaming industry that means that we
will choose to do not to do business
with a number of
partners or choose to turn away business
because we're seeing to be potentially
marketing to too young of a group that
being in the early 20s even if it's
legal we choose to go well above the law
the company is it I'm impressed by the
company because I don't gamble by the
way a lot of my colleagues at corporate
don't gamble we tend to be impressed I'm
impressed by the fact that the company
is so generous in giving in terms of
what we do is a is their own community
so if you look at the volunteer programs
every supervisor went up around the
country is asked to participate in
volunteer boards or give X number of
hours per quarter and you connect that
to the environmental side the fact that
we have had no resistance and just a lot
of positive intent and corporation when
our top-down strategy came down was I
guess it's highly unusual to have that
level of collaboration and I like a joke
around by saying that there isn't a you
don't really hear a no or you don't hear
anyone say no and caesars internally
between property property corporate
because it's the the culture of the
company it's to take on and to it's a
very entrepreneurial climate for the
size of the company that we are which is
what interests me and staying there as
well so there's another attention that's
a little bit just I think really
fascinating and fun and that you touched
on with the irresistibility there's this
tension in gambling that you know
gambling is about is kind of sexy
staying at a luxury hotel it's like all
about abandoned like losing yourself not
thinking about things not being
responsible on the other hand the
stereotype of grain is very responsible
very dependable and a little bit stuck
in kind of hemp and hippies and
and and hippie at heart I don't look
like it if you get hurt a little
humorless so how do you balance that
tension from a branding and
communications standpoint yeah it's a
great question um so when Gwen and I
when Gwen and caesars & Saatchi started
working together she came to us with
this amazing program called code GREEN
which had been up and running for six
years I think at that point and had
incredible results attached to it in
terms of achieving its goals in carbon
and water and energy reduction and so
the first thing we say is wow there's
there's serious intention here this is a
really cool program they're actually
measuring their data which is something
people often come back to instead of
start with and so the fact that they had
started with it was fantastic and then
she said but we need this to mean
something to consumers and that was our
challenge was how do you translate code
GREEN into something that would be
appealing and actually motivating for
consumers and she had also had data that
showed that consumers the ones who knew
about it actually recognized and
appreciated what caesars was doing so we
did our what we call our discovery
process and sort of figuring this out
and we came back to her with what now
feels like a very obvious conclusion
which was people who are at a
bachelorette party in Las Vegas and
they're to gamble and party and have fun
don't care about carbon the end that was
that was sort of in but that didn't
answer the question the question was
okay they don't care but that still
doesn't answer the question of how are
we going to get them to care and so that
was sort of the next phase of our work
and really thinking through how to make
a message that wasn't so sort of
hammering over your head that you had to
sort of feel guilty because you just
wanted to play blackjack but instead was
a message that sort of buoyed the
experience of the guests instead by
creating an environment that was a
little healthier and a little bit better
and so there was a lot of just we came
up with a strategy which is now being
implemented
in some of the properties that we called
the quiet surround which was to continue
to do all the work that caesars was
doing with code GREEN and and
communicated in a much subtler way so
that the guests who really does care
because they do exist and has an
opportunity to learn what they want to
learn through some clues and and cues
that are in the properties and those who
are there just to have a good time may
not be interested in learning more but
they're still getting the benefit of the
work that caesars is doing by creating
this environment that is a little bit
healthier and better for the world so it
leads to another tension which I don't
know if you want to go there quite yet
but is you know for companies you need
the brands we work with now a lot of
them will say our consumers don't want
it they haven't indicated through
research and polling and everything else
that they want this stuff and our
responses who cares if they want it you
as an organization need to be ahead of
your consumers because you're going to
be out of business if you don't and
you're not doing what you need to do as
an organization so caesars is doing what
it needs to do as a leading company and
helping its consumers understand the
benefit benefits of that in a way that's
really on brand in terms of the
experience you have when you're in a
property mm-hmm and I and I think that
quiets around that approach is
particularly interests interesting like
used in a casino or in luxury property
hotel properties because i think these
industries have have always known really
well how to do this so i think i don't
know if you can think of an industry
other than gambling that actually does a
better job of using an understanding of
psychology to nudge behavior right so so
is there something that anything that
you took from the industry as you
thought of these this like experiential
experiential marketing any any tricks of
the trade done overwhelmed with customer
yeah I was just it was it's really a
subtle surrounding we call equal
simplicity approach you just I mean our
marketers would love to find ways to
sell space to advertisers in the casino
itself I mean so you're constantly going
through this if they're not doing it for
if you know another way to fight to get
more revenue how do we get airtime in in
the casino floor so there's a lot of
different touch points that any age
group it helped us to come across
everything from a button that would be
highlighting a environmentally friendly
feature on lighting or recycling that's
often a question when it's our customers
it's are you doing anything because I
don't say in your recycling bins front
of house it's we recycle everything we
sort through trash back of house and
that's these you know little eco little
signs that tell the customer what we're
doing we're cycling back of house
everything from there to of pre and post
visits we're incorporating much more
around into our existing mechanism so
the last thing you want to tell a
marketer is let's create another
mechanism for I'll be you know the 10
channels or what have you that we're
communicating through so it's it's
tagging on these subtle messages on
direct direct mail piece as we're trying
to move more to email or website or
meetings of convention business these
touch points and there you have to
constantly look at ways to refresh it
but in a big way heavily educate you
your marketers and what you're trying to
achieve and it's not all about the
objects it's about supporting the larger
program behind the scenes mm-hmm and
that's that's a challenge right because
it's not necessarily that you own the
campaign but you're working with
existing campaigns and trying to augment
them is that what I'm understanding
where you add to them I mean if there's
a camp and email campaign going out for
guests you want to make sure that your
message is part of that great yeah so
that's that's where we got such as
helped to create what we call a code
GREEN catalog so properties every
property has to implement X number of of
code GREEN messages on these different
five or six different mediums from
employee
you